on analyse on va tout de suite retrouvé
jocelyn coulon je vous rappelle qu'il
est chercheur au centre d'études et de
recherches internationales de
l'université de montréal est on sait les
politiques aussi de lancer ministre des
affaires étrangères stéphane dion
bonsoir monsieur coulon bonsoir alors on
vous retrouve en europe vous êtes
précisément en france aujourd'hui vous
avez donc ce point de vue mais vu de
france avec tous ces événements ça bouge
énormément la pieve parlons de kiev avec
ces hommes qui se sont qui ont très peu
d'expérience militaire dans certains
cols qui joignent les troupes de l'armée
une ville de loi 3 millions d'habitants
walker millions d'habitants oui on se
demandait combien de temps vont-ils
pouvoir tenir vous savez moi je trouve
qu'on est dans la situation que l'on a
vécu en 2003 lors de l'invasion de
l'irak par les états unis qu'est ce que
les états unis ont dit au gouvernement
irakien rendez vous ou bien on vous
écrase eh bien c'est exactement ce qui
est arrivé les etats unis ont ils
également envahi l'irak ont tué des
centaines de milliers de personnes ont
plongé la région dans un bain de sang
ils n'ont jamais été sanctionné pour ses
crimes aujourd'hui en ukraine on risque
de revivre ça parce que c'est pas vrai
que de distribuer 18000 fusil à quatre
millions d'habitants ça va empêcher les
troupes russes d'envahir et d'occuper
kiev et les autres grandes villes donc
il faut trouver une solution pour éviter
ce même sens parlons-en de ses solutions
alors parlons d'abord de l'otan parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu rencontre encore
un point de presse par la suite le temps
ne s'engage pas dans confie le nom va
rester ou pourtour d'une certaine façon
essayer de sécuriser tous ces pays qui
entourent ce côté est entrons l'ukraine
mais oui mais l'otan n'a jamais eu
l'intention vraiment de s'impliquer et
d'aller porter secours à l'ukraine nous
avons dit il conduit nous ce sont les
pays occidentaux depuis le début de
cette crise on peut faire remonter à
2014 lors de l'annexion de la crimée
mais disons depuis le début décembre
lorsque vous tiennent envoyé célèbre aux
gouvernements occidentaux que jamais on
utiliserait la force pour défendre luc m
parce que l'ukraine n'est pas membre de
l'otan mais en plus on ne veut pas de
conflit avec la russie puisque ça
pourrait dégénérer vers un conflit
nucléaire à partir du moment où vous
envoyer le signal à la russie que vous
n'allez pas défendre l'ukraine et bien
vous ouvrait un boulevard pour les
russes pour leur permettre de rentrer en
ukraine et de faire ce qu'ils veulent
alors l'otan peut bien faire toutes les
déclarations qu'elle veut elle peut
envoyer le nombre de soldats qu'elle
veut dans les pays membres de l'otan ça
ne changera rien à la situation
moi je pense que la façon d'ouvrir une
négociation où le dialogue c'est pour
les ukrainiens qui sont tous seuls
d'accepter certaines des conditions
de l'adie mire poutine ça nous éviterait
un scénario à l'irakienne
les ukrainiens ressortissants qui vivent
au canada vous écoute ce soir et doit
saisir sa peau de bon sens on peut pas
on peut prier et célébrer on peut pas se
rendre c'est à dire s'ils baissent pas
les bras qui va venir les défendre et
comment vont-ils se défend contre une
force 10 fois supérieur à leur force
faisait les ukrainiens sont très mal a
remis ils sont pas très bien entraînés
puisque nous avions des missions
militaires pour entraîner l'armée
ukrainienne allées sont face à un géant
au même titre que l'irak était face à un
géant et s'ils veulent pas et écrase il
faut éviter le pire il faut éviter le
bain de sang est la seule façon de le
faire et bien malheureusement c'est de
s'asseoir avec l'agresseur pour essayer
thierry le meilleur compromis possible
c'est terrible à dire mais c'est ainsi
il ya eu cette possibilité de
négociation qui a été invoqué par
monsieur poutine lui-même semble-t-il à
te fait oui lady je pourrais délégué une
équipe a means donc on irait en
biélorussie en biélorussie et on négocie
rêve est d'abord on négocierait avec qui
ont négocié alors c est une bonne
question rires effectivement puisque on
a là on a l'impression que poutine veut
se débarrasser du gouvernement un
mensuel il s'agit de voir dans les
prochaines heures dans les prochains
jours si c'est vraiment le cas alors
peut-être qu'il pourrait y avoir une
délégation du président des dden ski qui
se rend à minsk pour négocier mais il
faut négocier sur quelque chose et
poutine a déjà posé deux conditions
mardi cette semaine il a dit l'ukraine
doit renoncer formellement demandé son
adhésion à l'otan et deuxièmement
l'ukraine doit proclamer un statut de
neutralité comme la finlande ou
l'autriche ça c'est les deux conditions
essentielles
en tout cas selon poutine si on peut le
croire pour mettre fin au conflit il y
aura d'autres choses bien entendu qui y
compris dans les lettres que poutine
envoyé aux occidentaux concernant par
exemple une nouvelle discussion sur une
architecture de sécurité européenne où
tous les pays européens seraient partis
pour un homme j'aimerais qu'on parle la
position du canada la dame se coulon
comment vous la voyez comme monsieur
trudeau vient de prendre la parole parle
de sanction supplémentaire lui que lui
il est tout à fait favorable à ce qu'on
retire la russie de ce système bancaire
swift là alors quand il y en a eu
tellement d'impact pour le canada mais y
en aurait beaucoup plus pour les pays
européens qui voient leur tendent aussi
de l'énergie qui provient de la lucide
alors écoutez je pense que les pays
occidentaux en ce moment font de la
figuration il gesticule pour montrer à
l'eau opinions publiques qu'il faut
quelque chose mais en fait il ne faut
pas grand-chose parce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas faire grand chose et il faut bien qu
il faut bien comprendre que les
sanctions qui ont été adoptées ne vont
pas assez loin il faudrait vraiment
frappé le secteur énergétique
mais si vous frappez le secteur
énergétique russe eh bien vous frapper
plusieurs pays européens qui dépendent à
100% de leur approvisionnement
énergétique
je pense en particulier aux pays baltes
ou à l'autriche donc c'est pour ça qu'il
ya encore une division où le 5 des
occidentaux au sujet de l'ampleur des
des sanctions on a l'impression
finalement que beaucoup de pays qui sont
pris en otage d'une certaine façon par
la russie c'est qu'on est dans une
économie mondialisée seul et ce n'est
plus
l'union soviétique d'il ya 25 ou 30 ans
qui était isolé dans son bloc mais qui
avait très peu de rapports avec le reste
du monde
aujourd'hui la russie est intégrée dans
l'économie mondiale je regardais
aujourd'hui les réactions de la chine de
l'inde du brésil et de bien d'autres
pays qui ne condamne pas l'agression
ukrainienne évidemment il soulève des
questions et demande à ce qu'il y ait un
cessez le feu mais vous voyez que les
rapports de force sont très différents
aujourd'hui qu'il y a trente ans et
l'occident n'est plus en mesure de
dicter les conditions de l'ordre mondial
c'est extrêmement intéressant éclairant
c'est cette entrevue merci beaucoup
monsieur coulon
c'est moi qui vous remercie gertie
beaucoup